Speaker 1: Pure joy is the way that Rolling
Stone describes the emotional circumstances
among staffers at Fox News over the
firing of propagandist Tucker Carlson.
This is just delightful to see. Fox News
and Tucker Carlson have parted ways. He's
been fired. The rest of the network seems
thrilled. Writes this Rolling Stone article,
quote, Pure joy. One Fox reporter told Rolling
Stone of their reaction to the split. No one
is untouchable. It's a great day for America and
for the real journalists who work hard every day
to deliver the news at Fox. So I don't know how
many of them there are. A producer added, quote,
It was a good move to part ways with Tucker. He
knowingly spread lies throughout his time at Fox,
but I fear management will replace him with
someone who is just like him. So there probably
won't be any real change. As I suggested earlier
in the show, a network correspondent said, quote,
Good riddance. For a while there, it seemed
like he was running the network. This clearly
is a message that is not in the interim. It's a
morale boost for sure. So a lot of people at Fox
happy with this this decision. And I think it's
important to, again, insert into this discussion.
There is no reason whatsoever to believe. That
Tucker Carlson was fired because his on air
message became incompatible with the ideology
of Fox News. Everything we know is that these
are all really sort of like personnel and
legal issues. Tucker Carlson fomented the
storylines that got Fox News sued by Dominion
and paying out almost $800 million and currently
under lawsuit by Smartmatic, potentially paying
out even more money. Tucker was part of that.
Tucker was attacking Fox Management in text
messages, which we learned about because of
that lawsuit. Tucker And alleged harassment
taking place in his staff among his staff.
Environment has now led to a lawsuit by a woman.
And the targeting of Ray Epps may lead to another
lawsuit against Tucker Carlson and his program. So
he became a legal problem. He became a headache.
He became a problem employee, essentially.
But it is not because Fox News decided, oh,
we really shouldn't have that ideology. Needless
to say, the fact that Fox staffers are so thrilled
about this is fascinating. Another article from
The L.A. Times writes, Tucker Carlson producer's
discrimination claims go beyond Dominion scandal.
This is an I just lost the article. I don't know
what. Abby Grossberg sued FOX. Fox News Tucker
and several producers late yesterday, alleging
the network is rife with sexist, misogynistic
and abusive behavior. There are people already
saying that none of these allegations are true
and there are people saying, obviously they are.
We have a lawsuit, it's going to be adjudicated.
But the lawsuit is another problem. A Grossberg
lawsuit alleges discrimination based on gender,
religion and disability. She alleges that, quote,
constant bullying and gaslighting caused her,
quote, so much stress and anxiety that her stomach
ulcers flared up and she was in excruciating
pain. So that is going to be investigated. That
is going to be looked at. And then, of course, we
have the potentially forthcoming lawsuit from Ray
Epps. Not good for Fox News. It was not mutual.
Tucker was fired. But if anybody is happy here,
other than millions of Americans who rightly
assess that Tucker was damaging the country,
it is Fox News staffers themselves. Pure
joy, the exact quote from Rolling Stone